mit ihrem einsatz belegen wir kultur
swisslos wünscht ihnen viel vergnügen
es ist kein jahresende wie sonst
über allem schwebt das bedrohliche virus
kulturplatz fragt wie gelingt es trotz
allem die besinnliche zeit zu genießen
[Musik]
das
willkommen auf dem kulturplatz heute
nehme ich sie mit an einen ganz privaten
ort in eine stille hütte im glarnerland
hier oben tanke ich aufnehme ich abstand
vom alltag und das können wir momentan
alle gut gebrauchen 2020 was für ein ja
es hat uns herausgefordert dieses jahr
und es ist noch nicht vorbei
weihnachten steht vor der tür und wir
alle sind verunsichert wie können wir
mit unseren liebsten überhaupt feiern
wir haben ratgeber könig rolf dobelli
gefragt wie wir gelassen über die
festtage kommen und wir haben noch last
minute geschenk tipps für sie
[Musik]
so
schön sind hier weihnachten steht vor
der tür und ich kann mich nicht erinnern
wann dieses fest der familie und des
zusammenseins schon einmal unter so
unsicheren vorzeichen stand ja so kommen
wir gut über die festtage das ist die
frage antworten holen wir uns beim
ratgeber könig rolf dobelli und da seine
frau claudia maria buß psychologischer
romane über die inneren wege zum glück
schreibt wollten wir von beiden wissen
wie überstehen wir weihnachten 2020 wie
der grinch ist corona angetreten und die
schönste zeit des jahres zu vermiesen
gefährlicher aero sohle wabern in der
luft statt kontemplation droht
kontamination die bescherung besteht aus
gefahren warnungen und verboten
wer feiert hat gewissensbisse wer
verzichtet fällt den depressionen so
traurige das muss nicht sein sagen rolf
dobelli und ehefrau clara maria bagus
entscheidend sei die richtige
einstellung
die studierte psychologin publiziert
erfolgreich romane über die individuelle
suche nach dem glück philosoph und
kolumnist rolf dobelli ist bekannt für
bestseller über die kunst des klaren
denkens und des guten lebens wie wappnet
sich der philosoph für die feiertage
stets muss ich eigentlich ein
lebensphilosophie oder am besten hilft
ist illusorisch es als deutsches wort
seele ruhe und beginnen ihre urkunde
über verschiedene werkzeuge über
gedankliche wichtige ice züge und
strecken sind 2000 jahre alt ist eine
sache wo man könnte flossen die sachen
etwas was mich hilflos sind sind die
ziele sind sie wünsche sich dass dank
teilweise sogar diese emotionen
es ist viel geschehen konzentriert sich
auf das kundenverhalten hufe negative
toxische emotionen automatisch aus dem
labor weihnachten ist so eine magische
zeit und diese magie fällt jetzt weg das
einzige das man wirklich ändern kann ist
die sichtweise auf die dinge dass es
ähnlich dem historismus auch in der
psychologie kann man ja nur gefühle
ändern über das denken und wir können
unsere gedanken ja nicht beeinflussen
unser hirn produziert die gedanken aber
wir können sie lenken wir können uns zum
beispiel wenn man sehr bewusst denkt
entscheiden ob wir verharren wollen dem
jammern oder sagen wollen okay es ist
einfach so psychologie und philosophie
reagieren gleich auf diese krise mit
akzeptanz
wichtig ist die kommunikation nicht
abbrechen zu lassen
das sind mir noch im mittel oft mit
anderen sie ist kompliziert
ich rufe telefonat als video calls ist
ein rückschlag für für mich persönlich
ich habe ihn schon vorgeschlagen unsere
person zu führen
und wenn positives denken nicht mehr
hilft es gibt einen unterschied zwischen
belastenden gefühlen und welche die man
einfach nicht mehr erträgt und das finde
ich einen ganz wichtigen punkt gerade in
der korona zeit wenn man es nicht mehr
steuern kann die gedanken nicht mehr
steuern kann und wirklich in die
depression fällt dann keine scheu und
keine scham hilfe in anspruch zu nehmen
zum arzt gehen und ein antidepressiva
nehmen ist nichts wofür man sich schämen
muss und zum jahreswechsel dinner for
one
keine panik meint historiker silvester
werde sowieso überschätzt
neue ressorts funktioniere die etwas mit
psychologie um sich das neue logo mit
dem iran jede tagesbeste egal was es
glaubt für einen zufälligen tag im jahr
ist aber das kolossale feuerwerk der
kollektive countdown die rauschende
party all dieser reinigenden rituale
fallen weg
gibt es dafür ersatz während ried sturm
es geht ja ums loslassen ums loslassen
von allem was was was zu schweres gepäck
ist und auch menschen die haben nicht
gut tun dinge die passiert sind was wir
machen
wir schreiben netten namen oder
situationen die wirklich schlimm band
für unser leben
schreiben sie auf dem kärtchen und dann
verbrennen wir die und zwar noch im
alten jahr zehn vor zwölf schale
aufgestellt kärtchen wen hast du und
haben uns da noch abgestimmt und haben
das wirklich verbrannt und das war so
ein schönes los lassen weil wir mussten
auch nicht mehr darüber sprechen am
nächsten tag das entspannte fazit bei
latte und cappuccino optimismus bewahren
[Musik]
so ein weihnachten will ich auch peilen
jetzt ist jeder natürlich sehr auf sich
zurückgeworfen
aber die tage gehen auch vorbei wir sind
alle betroffen und wir sagen uns
nächstes jahr wird die party um so
größer na denn
frohe festtage
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ja ich glaube dass es hier waren wird im
januar hätte friedrich dürrenmatt seinen
hundertsten geburtstag feiern können
doch der mord hat sich bereits vor 30
jahren aus dem staub gemacht wie er
selbst formulierte
was aber hat uns der pfarrer sohn der
auszog ein großer schriftsteller zu
werden heute noch zu sagen gerade in
diesen zeiten wir finden eine ganze
menge wenn ich trostloses trauerspiel
welch unfassbares drama dezember
die dunkelste zeit des jahres und als
krönender abschluss eine nicht zu
bändigende pandemie viele wähnen sich in
einer art tunnel sehen schwarz
friedrich dürrenmatt hätte an dieser
geschichte wohl seine helle freude
gehabt so grotesk überhöht wie sie
scheint winzigkeit das glaube ich meine
ganze schriftstellerei das sind im
grunde ganz harmlose geschichten wie der
tunnel zum beispiel weil ich sage das
ist ein ganz ein ganz kleiner tunnel für
mich prozess eingang der höhle in seiner
erzählung der tunnel lässt dürrenmatt
einen studenten von bern nach zürich
pendelt an die uni doch bei dieser einen
vaart will der tunnel kein ende nehmen
für ulrich weber dürrenmatt biograf und
kurator des dürrenmatt nachlasses im
schweizerischen literaturarchiv in bern
steht fest der junge mann ist
dürrenmatts alter ego studie ja bereits
nach unserer küste die stanz darstellt
wie marokko für ihre das ist wm zweiter
weltkrieg wo eigentlich quasi um trägt
jeans trägt im rückblick stellte
stellten schulter sehen
orientierungslose zieht da habe ich
gewusst was zu sehen wer der wahre
künstlerische ambitionen hacker
gleichzeitig büßt fast aus der schweiz
aus der welt wenn das der autor und ganz
schwierige phase sein persönliches
dilemma das weltpolitische grauen und
auch die enorme verunsicherung während
des kalten krieges all das gipfelt in
der zugfahrt die aus den fugen gerät
auch heute scheint das leben außer
kontrolle
viele fühlen sich hilflos macht ratlos
haben eine art tunnelblick die sehr auf
corona fixiert fokussiert sind die alle
nachrichten lesen jede zahl sofort
wissen müssen jedes interview jede
pressekonferenz verfolgen und es gibt
jene die die bedrohung ignorieren
negieren auch ein tunnelblick bekräftigt
steffi weit
die psychiaterin rät uns corona nicht
auszublenden
aber dringend dazu unser blickfeld zu
erweitern damit wir die lichten momente
des tages die es durchaus gibt überhaupt
registrieren
und dann ist es wichtig diese
lichtblicke auch wirklich wahrzunehmen
und da kann es ganz ganz oft helfen wenn
man sich bewusst zum beispiel am abend
mit freunden mit familie mit irgend
jemandem der ein nahesteht austausch
über die lichtblicke die man am tag hat
und den uns als menschen und als
gesellschaft macht es aus dass wir für
einander einstehen
in dürrenmatts geschichte hingegen
herrscht keine menschlichkeit sondern
gnadenlose dunkelheit der meister kennt
kein pardon
was sollen wir tun steht zug führt nach
heimat
worauf der 24 jährige und sein gesicht
und schauspiel abzuwenden mit einer
gespenster
das wort
nicht
in diesen letzten worten liegt aber
nicht nur ein ende sondern auch eine
akzeptanz der situation ein loslassen
eine befreiung freiheit gepaart mit
einer gesalzenen prise humor
das ist nicht nichts das ist dürrenmatts
lebensrezept humor ist ein clown
möglichkeit vor freiheit die rede also
vor in der vergangenheit die räder welt
verkauf der strophe wobei nie weiß was
mit uns passiert sein gott gibt wusste
ein unendlicher humor haben da muss
wochen sind die freude da will die luft
zu ja das unerträgliche ertragbar machen
mit heiterer gelassenheit und mit
kreativität ein versuch wäre es wert der
offerte gott spielt diese geschichte
hätte hätte figur abzockern und die
katastrophe ihn als leiterinnen und
hattrick brachte ihnen versichern können
dürrenmatts machte sich in seiner
erzählung der tunnel einen spaß daraus
den zug ungebremst in richtung hölle
rasen zu lassen
wir dürfen weiter auf das erlösende
licht hoffen
immerhin eine aussicht
ja wenn sie noch tiefer gehen wollen in
dürrenmatts tunnel dann empfehlen wir
ihnen aktuell 1 dürner special auf sf
play mit seinen werken die art
dürrenmatt zu lesen das lohnt sich aber
auch immer wieder
ich habe aber heute einen ganz anderen
leser und literatur tipp für sie isabel
allende hat einmal ein kochbuch
geschrieben aphrodite eine feier der
sinne dieses buch begleitet mich seit
mehr als 20 jahren ich habe es verloren
muss das neu kaufen
es ist eine literarische anleitung für
sinnliches kochen mit rezepten die
heißen frivole pflaumen verliebt das
hühnchen oder milchreis zur seelischen
tröstung ein wunderbares
weihnachtsgeschenk
[Musik]
seit diesem jahr ist alles anders sie
verzichten auf umarmungen haben uns die
nähe schon fast ab trainiert doch was
macht das mit uns menschen wo wir doch
die berührungen so sehr brauchen ein
essay über ein jahr fast ohne haut an
haut alles sein auf dieser welt beginnt
mit ihr
sie ist unser erstes erschließen des
außen und des anderen
sie berichtet uns ständig unmittelbar
ohne filter vorurteilslos die berührung
nur gerade ist sie fast immer verboten
jeder andere ist eine potenzielle gefahr
nähe
nur auf eineinhalb meter was macht das
mit uns wenn wir das berühren aufgeben
drei menschen die es wissen könnten
theater regisseur falk richter
[Musik]
kunsthistorikerin miriam neumeister und
martin grunwald haptik forscher also es
gibt keine virtuelle nähe dass es das
funktioniert nicht also unsere spezies
empfindet mehr zu einem anderen menschen
immer auch in gewisser weise auch auf
der körperlichen dimension der tastsinn
ist unser erster sinn
lange bevor wir riechen schmecken hören
oder sehen kann fühlen wir
von klein auf entdecken wir die welt
maßgeblich durch berührung das angenehme
an ihr genauso wie das schmerzliche
berühren kann trösten oder verstören
jede berührung ist eine geschichte es
gibt die liebe als wichtiges thema es
gibt natürlich auch aggression gewalt
was man eben über gesten über
berührungen vermitteln kann
machtverhältnisse kann man
veranschaulichen
man kann auch religiöse gefühle
veranschaulichen und körperkontakt kann
rücksichtslos sein nicht nur in der
malerei während einer pandemie ist
unkontrolliertes berühren der sündenfall
schlechthin abstand halten deshalb heute
bürger tugend nur was geht mir damit auf
berührungen sind schon auch eine
wichtige vergewisserung dass ich
existiere also dass ich nicht über
jemand anders spüre das fällt einem dann
so auf dass man früher also vor kurbelt
9 sind noch also ganz oft vielleicht
auch so probleme oder was darüber auch
mal lösen konnte dass man sich den arm
genommen hat oder spannung auflösen
konnte touch also berühren heißt das nur
kurze zeit aufgeführte stück von falk
richter an den münchner kammerspielen
eine dystopie des nicht lügen dürfen
denn isolation das wird klar kann nicht
lange gut gehen
die leute werden ja auf jeden fall
unruhiger und unzufriedener verängstigt
also ich finde die spannungen innerhalb
der gesellschaft nehmen zu
auch so dass leute so bisschen
durchdrehen und und sich so
verschwörungs geschichten ausdenken also
ich finde das schon so dass wir so einen
erhöhten level an verrücktheit und nicht
mehr ganz geerdet sein haben es ist doch
seltsam
je mehr wir das sicherheit zuliebe auf
abstand gehen desto unsicherer fühlen
wir uns distanz halten ist auch deshalb
so schwer weil es dem widerspricht wie
wir für gewöhnlich auf gefahren
reagieren wenn man jetzt ohne diese
berührung reize innerhalb der
schwierigen gesellschaftlichen
gesamtsituation zurechtkommen muss dann
fördert das natürlich auch emotionen der
angst und der unsicherheit und
selbstwert problematik spielt auch eine
rolle ja also der berühmte menschheit
auch weniger angst sind wir nach der
pandemie nachhaltig berührungs gestört
unser verhältnis zu nähe hat sich schon
mal verschoben und soll das shakespeare
theater wie die leute damals zusammen
standen wie die im zuschauerraum waren
also die haben so im zuschauerraum
uriniert und haben da gespuckt und haben
da gegessen wenn wir das lesen dann
denken wird es kann nicht wahr sein dass
leute so unhygienisch zusammen gelebt
haben und es kann auch sein dass wir in
zwei jahren oder in fünf jahren denken
werden das was die leute waren so dicht
gedrängt in konzerten so ganz eng
aneinander mit fremden die wussten doch
gar nicht wer das ist und konnten doch
die kontakte gar nicht nachverfolgen wie
konnte das denn machen jemanden in den
arm nehmen sich anlehnen
ein klaps auf den rücken über
berührungen regulieren der stress nehmen
uns ängste entschärfen konflikte ein
haptisches vokabular das durch worte
allein nicht zu ersetzen ist
es gibt da diese lustigen gesten nur mit
dem ellenbogen oder mit dem fuß ja also
man versucht schon dem bedürfnis nach
körper kommunikation nachzukommen
irgendwie ein kontakt ereignis
herzustellen um wenigstens auf dieser
symbolischen geste sozusagen das
miteinander zu fördern
der mensch sieht besser was er zuvor
berührt den anderen und durch den
anderen auch sich selbst
[Musik]
aber auch dieses jahr hat die liebe
geblüht wenn auch gut versteckt so viel
hunger farbe und tino brandauer haben
den lockt auch im frühling genutzt um
liebeslieder zu schreiben entstanden ist
diese scheibe ich liebe dich mit
wunderbaren liedern poetisch prickelnd
wunderschön damit werden bestimmt gerne
liebe menschen beschenkt uns natürlich
auch der perfekte sound für mein leben
[Musik]
doch
wir geben ja aktuell kulturschaffenden
ein projekte wegen corona in der
schublade liegen eine chance für einen
auftritt bei uns und die zweite siegerin
aus unserem wettbewerb ist die tänzerin
miriam baraka sie hatte große pläne
dieses jahr
[Musik]
fixiert es ist für mich mir noch schnell
also ich finds wahrscheinlich wird sie
ohne die 1000 die bewegung und aber man
irgendwie hatte ich trotzdem immer
tanzen das ist mir im blut
[Musik]
auch dieses jahr hat miriam baraka viel
getanzt
doch seit corona ohne publikum die
tänzerin musste alle geplanten projekte
verschieben
als projekt du mir besonders am herzen
ich habe zeit wurde mir hätte 2000
palästina endlich mal gold vor der 1101
company und die haben wir keine reise
will die sind unterlag dank sie ihm
hätten im juli proben abfangen für die
ist es unmöglich die zürcherin fliegt
schon seit jahren eine besondere
beziehung zu wallis team
vor corona war sie regelmäßig im
gazastreifen und im westjordanland
dort leitet sie workshops und übte mit
lokalen tanz und theatergruppen
choreografin ein die sie vor ort
aufführten
das schlüsselmoment für ihr
künstlerisches engagement im glanz war
der mauerbau zwischen palästina und
israel
ich als auftrag an wir nicht verstanden
wie das ist für mich wie die letzte
lösung also dass wir anders möglich und
ich hat das recht berührt vielleicht
auch weil ich gerade mit dixie bin von
der orientalischen kultur
ich weiß es nicht genau es ist wirklich
mir jetzt das herz
ausgebildet in zeitgenössischem tanz in
der schweiz und in italien erweiterte
baraka ihren eigenen stil mit
orientalischen elementen
seit 20 jahren arbeitet und unterrichtet
sie als freischaffende tänzerin
nun wird der wunsch der wettbewerb
siegerin erfüllt auf der bühne des
zürcher tanzhauses zeigt sie ihre
improvisation entre deux darin funkelte
alles auf was back ups tanzsprache
repräsentiert ein mix von westlichen
tanz und folklore tänze des nahen ostens
und nordafrikas die wahlen die bewegung
gehöre zu der älteste tanzbewegung für
die menschheit und das hat mich wir
wohnten zurück zu den wurzeln und handel
das angefangen mit orientalischen tanzes
ist dürfte er spricht die erste
schwierige lage gemeinsam mit einer
befreundeten künstlerin experimentiert
sie mit orientalische ornamente und
malaga also der ganze körper es
ganzkörper tattoo und andere mal halt
gemacht mit verschiedene
architektonische relevant wird romantik
dem vorhand und da sich das
herzensprojekt wo man sitzt mit
projektion auf den boden
reduziert
mit diesem spektrum von eigenen
ausdrucksformen will die tänzerin
brücken bauen zwischen west und ost
obwohl zurzeit unklar ist wann sie ihre
projekte in palästina wieder aufnehmen
kann
kein virus vermag miriam barak als
leidenschaft zu dämpfen
das wo mich im tanz so fasziniert dass
gott wo es in worte fassen sondern ich
möchte dass ein betrachter überlassen tv
musiziert oder was er mit sich mitnimmt
[Musik]
ja am allerschönsten ist es hier oben im
bett muss man sagen nächste woche da
fällt der kulturplatz aus aber wir sehen
uns noch einmal im alten jahr am 30
dezember laden wir ein zu einer kultur
travolta
ich koche mit der kultur prominenz mit
dabei etwa der rapper stress aber jetzt
erst einmal von herzen friedliche
weihnachten bis bald wieder gute nacht
geht
[Musik]
euro
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur
swisslos